I suffer from depression.
Antidepressants is something my psychiatrist has recommended for years
This is something I did not want to do
I will try St. John's tea or mood enhancers
Very afraid of what side effects of the drug
I am afraid that if you take antidepressants they make depression more or less realistic
This is something I do not want to admit
Because, you know all you hear about the side effects of terrible antidepressants
All we hear about antidepressants
"My weight has increased after my use of antidepressants"
Or "Antidepressants cause me nausea"
Or "terrible things have happened"
But recently, I have experienced a bout of depression
This pushed me somewhat into madness
This has turned me into a difficult person to live with
Only if I've never been better
The psychiatrist raised the subject of antidepressants again
"What if I just tried antidepressants, I tried the herbs that you wanted to try"
"I used antidepressants, my wife used antidepressants, and both of us helped tremendously"
"We used antidepressants from 10 to 15 years old to try it"
I reached the point of my life where I realized
I am active in the field of protection from suicide, especially
In the youth, I am someone who fights to remove the stigma surrounding mental illness and mental illness
I pay to make myself a lot of money to help me in my life
I do not listen to his advice, and I did not listen to this part of his advice
for many years
This is something I should try, maybe it will help me or maybe not
But it is a solution that I can try.
I do not argue that all people should use drugs
I just think that if a licensed psychologist advises me to use drugs for many years
Maybe this is something I should try
right right? Yeah
There is no
I have a sister who committed suicide, this means that every member of my family increases the probability of suicide 50%
My doctor has a very good explanation
Or, a way to address my fears, he said to me,
"If my family suffers from allergies, if I do not take allergy, I'll be miserable"
Can I recover from my sensitivity? No, this is just the allergy that I was born with
"You have depression, depression in your genes, you're more prone to depression," he said.
I know this is like self-congratulation, but I'm proud of myself.
I took steps towards my mental health
And whether this step does not do or do anything for the quality of my life
This is something I did not want to do
Because of stereotypes that follow antidepressants, because of my fear, and because of my feeling of insecurity
What would people think when they knew I was using antidepressants?
And all these stupid things
I do not want to be afraid of small things
And I know that they do not seem to me to do this
Because of my expressions about myself online but
As you know, when something small comes out of control enter into this vortex of
Emotional disorder. Or if you read an article on Facebook about the death of a sad rabbit
I go into a whirlwind of bad mood and I can not get out of it
I am quick to annoy daily
My usual mood is that I am easily upset and very sad and miserable
If using the medicine will give me a better life
Or makes me a more entertaining person or makes me a happier person
I must be ready to be impressed because
That's really what I want. Steps have been taken
To get to my house
Except for medicines.
So .... this is just a funny * voice * a chapter in the life of a journey,
I do not know .. I feel strange to make a video about it.
The title says it all
I have not used the medicine yet so I do not know any side effects
I just took a step
Where is my Academy Award? Where is my prize?
* Silly sound *
Anna Anna, stay strong